[Music]
you
well this piece is based on a couple of
different sound sounds from the film
that was already happening before yeah
we have a wave of things in a way the
theme the line demon yeah we have the
River Q which is the the harp and our
obscene with this long shallow line and
that in ways you know going through the
whole movie in different variations yeah
and we have prepared piano with a little
bit yeah like the flashback to the
childhood and it's in a way that this is
a great scene because in a way it's sort
of all of the ideas coming together that
we were working on and Garth was working
on because we created this lion theme
that is this perpetual theme of movement
and then the prepared piano is such a
representation of him as a child and
when he was in India and all of these
textures and the cello line that comes
in is it's almost like the sound of his
mother the warmth the love and and
there's he's in the moment of searching
but there's also this spiritual time
line that that is threaded through the
film and this represents all of that
it's him feeling out of his body and in
another place but he's also very much in
the present of it of his situation rate
which which was home he he's he's there
he's feeling completely lost he's
imagining his mother but so this I think
this this scene it brings so
ideas and we were working on together
absolutely especially also the journey I
mean with with a train ride and the
movement in the music I think that yes
very catered very well here
and it's one of the few times that he's
living in both the past and present you
know it's and it really comes together
here he's this is where he you feel his
complete division inside of himself and
you see all he's really picturing
himself back home but he's also in
Tasmania in front of a map in his
computer
I remember when I saw this for the
sequence the first time I was really
skeptical if I can like write some music
for this because it's maybe the most
maybe distance scene in that like the
beginning yeah this cold wall where he
said hand now you know but then it
switches into the warmth of India and
him in between and like a search so I I
think it the whole journey in the queue
came pretty well together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we were the last people to come in and
film they had a they were pretty close
to final edit and so when we saw it it
was pretty emotional impact was was
already very strong and so we knew that
we had to jump in into it pretty quickly
and and we both were in our separate
studios you were in mistletoe I was in
Dusseldorf you were and lost no no you
were at that time in Berlin in the first
I think when we talked first the value
and then you walked when you flew over
to Los Angeles Angeles yeah and we were
working in our own separate studios just
getting into the just giving into the
film into the emotional part of the film
and and then you came to Los Angeles and
we spent about a month of blood sweat
and tears but it was I remember that
when we saw the movie the first time
that we were quite you know so deeply
impressed I think we well we were a
little bit like so how can we actually
achieve you know to make good like good
music to support actually the
another story sensitive now I remember
the scene when I saw the film for the
first time even with the tent music it
it got me and I I think I think I cried
so much making music because every time
I'd watch some scenes just I couldn't
help but feel so emotional
[Music]
I think what Garth
heard in both of our music is I think
both of us have a there's always a sense
of longing in our music and I think that
that's something that he connected with
and wanted us to bring in a very
truthful way to his film I remember that
we started to shape our own ideas to
some of the cues in the beginning but I
think we were pretty fast already
sending music back and forth and it was
changing constantly and yeah feeling it
was not like I was doing a cue and it
was completely finished
it was mostly they were sending pieces
back and forth yeah and I think we the
first month that we were in our own
space wasn't so much when we came up
with themes or all of the ideas it was
more figuring out the instrumentation
giving up the town and then when we got
together I felt like we brought all the
bits and pieces together and it changed
and evolved and especially with God and
his collaboration you need to face
reality
reality
you can idea what it's like knowing my
real brother and mother spend every day
of their lives looking for me every day
my real brother screams my name
and you imagine the pain they must be in
not knowing where I am huh 25 years
loose 25400 culinary is one of our
privileged lives makes me see I have to
follow time they need to know
Garth had tempt a lot of our music in
the film so there was already a voice of
piano being a book we booked piano
players and approaching it in different
ways the the piano seemed always seemed
to be a great instrument because we
never wanted to make a big score we
wanted it to feel that you were
following through this journey but we
needed the the emotional dynamics of
then the piano can be so dynamic it's in
a way it's a full orchestra of the bay
issue of everything into the eyes and
you have percussion elements and and
everything that you bring with prepared
piano I think it just felt like every
cue had you're touching my touch inside
of it in some way and I think that's why
it feels so good easily we already
recorded so much different music a way
which I really sometimes I feel like
okay I'm doing the prepared piano you're
getting the clean piano yeah but I have
a feeling that we I mean we both played
in bands we did like many weird kind of
experiments in knowledge I have a
feeling that this comes sometimes in
those scenes that comes all together I
personally feel that is very
the big pleasure of the score
[Music]
you